[Musique]
bonjour emmanuel de reynal bonjour
président de l'association patronale
contact entreprises merci d'être avec
nous à l'occasion de ce livre orange
cette fois ci un livre orange après le
livre bleu que qui nous avait été
présenté en février 2014 et nous sommes
toujours dans la même philosophie des
livrets qui sont en fait des
propositions des chefs d'entreprise de
martiniquais pour relancer pour booster
pour dynamiser notre pays et manuel de
reynal oui nous sommes inscrits dans
cette démarche de proposer donc des
jeunes entreprises membres de contact
entreprises et pour ce dernier livre
membre également de la cpe
ces pme pardon ont décidé ont choisi de
participer à la proposition collective
il ya une différence fondamentale entre
le livret bleu de 2014 et celui orange
d'aujourd'hui dans le livre le livre
bleu de 2010 2014 avait pour objectif là
pour le coup de dessiner une vision
prospective de la martinique est
d'apporter des idées on va dire en
rupture d'inviter les martiniquais
réfléchir aux moyens de bousculer un
petit peu les les normes pour faire
avancer des idées
ce livre d'aujourd'hui que nous sentons
donc ce matin qui s'appelle martin
qu'attractive lui par nos constats qui
nous alarme qui est le constat du choc
démographique
oui ils sont dans l'arctique perd chaque
année l'équivalent d'une commune comme
les anses d'arlet en terme de population
exactement 3500 habitants en moins
chaque année on va dans un mur terrible
qui nous conduit à l'appauvrissement si
on ne fait rien donc on est on est très
effaré par ce déclin
ce sont des départs puisque la natalité
et la mortalité ne change pas c'est
vraiment le départ à cause du manque
d'attractivité de notre île
alors c'est exactement le boucle là
l'aboutissement de la réflexion c'est de
se dire si on ne part quand on constate
une population qui décroît au temps et
qui vieillit dans les mêmes proportions
on a deux options la première c'est soin
d'adapter notre économie à ce fait
démographique et là il ya eu pas mal de
réflexion qui ont été menées notamment
sur l'économie du vieillissement la
silver economy et la deuxième posture et
celle qu'on choisit aujourd'hui
d'adopter c'est de se dire que peut-on
faire que doit en faire si on veut
inverser les courbes
alors comment alors inversé les courbes
c'est clairement quelles sont les
mesures à prendre quelle soit des idées
à mettre sur la table pour faire venir
les gens pour faire revenir des
martiniquais et pour empêcher les forces
vives de partir et là on arrive
directement sur la problématique de
l'attractivité way et il faut simplement
constater que si à cette hémorragie qui
est très particulière et très violente
c'est parce que la martinique
aujourd'hui perd de son attractivité et
faudrait déjà par exemple les manuels de
reynal stopper ce qu'on appelle de plus
en plus le martinique bashing c'est à
dire le dénigrement systématique de
notre pays de sa population c'est un
volet que nous exprimons d'ailleurs dans
notre document effectivement le
martinique beijing cette tendance que
l'on a à ne voit que le verre à moitié
vide chez nous est une tendance
mortifère il faut absolument changer de
braquet changer de d'options et je vais
pas mettre non plus là mais devant les
yeux lorsqu'on dit que le transport ça
ne fonctionne pas en martinique
c'est une réalité c'est pas du bashing
ça c'est une réalité c'est un constat il
y à des réalités en effet qui expliquent
le désenchantement des populations quand
la machine ne fonctionne pas quand les
institutions ne fonctionnent pas quand
les organisations sont en panne quand
les dossiers prennent du temps à sortir
quand les investisseurs n'arrivent pas à
faire aboutir leurs dossiers vrai que
vous y êtes entré dans le bafing
on ne peut pas on ne peut que constater
des départs c'est une réalité on alias
tâter le constater ce soir seulement
faire du bashing alors comment faire
pour bouygues cité soleil un vrai
travail à faire sur nous mêmes pour
pouvoir nettoyer les esprits vous
écrivez dans votre livre
oui nettoyer esprit réparer la machine
revend un petit peu nous nous
une manière de fonctionner pendant que
les choses fonctionnent mieux soit plus
efficace et que ceux qui veulent
produire ici venir ici ou où vivre chez
nous le puisse le faire convenablement
alors comment produire et manier de
reynal comment produire du discours
positif lorsqu'internet ça ne fonctionne
pas que ça coûte très cher pour
apprendre billets d'avion ça coûte trop
cher
lorsque le tcsp ne fonctionne pas
lorsque les dossiers restent sans
réponse comment être positif qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire
alors bon d'abord là vous avez grainé
tous nos fins un chapelet de deux points
négatifs et je peux aussi vous citer d
un chapelet de points positifs frais
parce que nous avons des atouts à
marieville peu de vrais atouts encore
faut-il peut-être mettre l'accent dessus
et construire sur nos atouts donc ça a
mis l'accent par exemple suffisamment
sur ce rhum d'appellation d'origine
contrôlée recherché par plus de 120 pays
dans le monde
on ne sait pas le vendre davantage en
dessous et vous avez complètement raison
de parler de ce volet là puisque nous on
propose dans nos solutions très
concrètement c'est de construire des
stratégies territoriales attractivité
fondées sur nos atouts on avait décelé
deux fins deux grands chapitres dans les
travaux du livre bleu le chapitre de
l'économie bleus en exploitant au mieux
le potentiel de la mer et et en tirant
profit notamment des flux de deux
bateaux en adaptant notre fiscalité et
nos équipements pour pouvoir en faire un
levier développement économique il ya là
de vrais vrai travail à faire et qui qui
pourraient réinstaller de la
productivité de la production sur notre
territoire
et puisque vous venez d'évoquer leurs
hommes l'ambition que l'on pourrait
avoir et simplement de dire comment la
martinique peut-elle devenir la capitale
mondiale du rhum et de manière entraîner
derrière cette idée l'industrie
l'agriculture et le tourisme
ce sera le patrimoine et la culture ce
que nous aimons notre rome personne va
vallonnier mais tout le monde sait aussi
que les distilleries n'appartiennent pas
aux martiniquais à quelques rares
exceptions mais je crois que là-dessus
il faut peut-être une fois qu'on a dit
ça
voyons maintenant ce qu'on peut en faire
de manière positive pour la martinique
[Musique]
oui vous avez bachinger j'essaie de
contrer ça prenons exemple sur ce qu'ont
fait d'autres pays regardez ce que ce
qu'a fait l'échos les causes d'un
territoire qui a construit son sa
dynamique économique sa dynamique
culturelle sa dynamique industrielle sa
dynamique touristique autour d'un
produit que le whisky
pourquoi la martigues ne ferait elle pas
avec son rhum ce que l'ecosse a su
faction whisky
pourquoi lamartine ne serait elle pas
faire avec son rhum ce que la ville de
bordeaux a su fait avec son vin voilà
des territoires qui ont pu complètement
prendre une position reconnue
mondialement avec un produit
d'excellence et sur ce plan là nous
n'avons pas à rougir nous avons le
meilleur du monde nous sommes le seul
romao c'est au monde alors c'est la
faute c'est la faute de qui puisque ça
ne suffit pas je crois que c'est une
faute collective je crois simplement que
c'est dans le jeu lorsqu'on regarde le
design des bouteilles de de rome on peut
pas jeter la pierre à toutes les équipes
de commerciaux qui cire le monde pour
pouvoir vendre ce rhum à tel point que
même les martiniquais qui veulent
consommer du rebond peur que la
consommation locale sera affectée par
l'exportation
oui je crois que là c'est la
responsabilité est un petit peu diffusés
multiples je crois qu'en martinique de
ce point de vue là un pays de plusieurs
tunnels manche où chacun avance dans sa
voix un peu fermée et qu'on gagnerait
peut-être à jouer collectif a joué
davantage collectif et à arrêter de
considérer que si on pousse tel bouton
ses pensées à lire telle catégorie peut
être égal à un bien commun intérêt
général à servir en mobilisant tout le
monde et je crois que ce sujet là le
tourisme le politique l'économique
doivent parler la même voie vous ne
demandez surtout aux martiniquais
emmanuel de rina vous demander de vivre
les choses de façon intense si on
mettait de l'intensité dans tout ce que
nous faisons martinique et que nous le
fassions nous le fassions savoir ce
serait peut-être
nous oui alors c'est vrai que là on
touche à ce n'est pas de la méthode coué
mais quand même
nous avons l'avantagé de vivre sur un
territoire qui peut être un des plus
beaux territoires du monde avec des
atouts que beaucoup de pays nous envient
et nous ne savons pas tiré profit de ces
atouts nous ne savons pas valoriser ses
atouts et nous avons malheureusement
tendance à plutôt nous dénigrer alors
que nous aurions de bonnes raisons de
deux d'être fier de ce qu'on est et de
l'endroit où l'on vit
lorsque vous parlez d intensité à vous
parler de tout ce qui est culturel de
tout ce qui est festif mais nous sommes
rattrapés par les réglementations suffit
qu on remette par exemple linden si
mauvais que l'y aider parade de carnaval
du vide et de carnaval et iront 10 mais
ça fait trop de brouillard et avec ça
c'est un état d'esprit qui est assez
destructeur la langue corse a rejoint le
un peu un comportement contre lequel il
faut lutter qui consiste à non pas
déroulé le tapis rouge devant les
porteurs de projet mais plutôt à tirer
des coups de fusil sur ce qu'ils ont
envie de faire des choses alors je
caricature mais on ne prenez pas loin de
cette réalité il y à ici un art unique
des porteurs de projets il a des talents
il y a des gens qui ont des idées ça
peut être monter des festivals ça peut
être monter des industries monter des
projets tout ça ça existe simplement est
ce que l'environnement aujourd'hui est
favorable à ce que ces projets émergent
deux premières finalement c'est la
politique
il y a le il ya l'environnement
politique et à l'environnement
réglementaire il à l'environnement
institutionnel tout ça devrait peut-être
changer de regard et et se mettre en en
faveur des porteurs de projets et manioc
de finale très sincèrement regarder dans
les yeux dit les choses et vraiment est
ce que les politiques peuvent être à la
hauteur de ce livre orange intitule
aujourd'hui martinique attractive
est ce que les politiques peuvent être à
la hauteur de du livret bleu de 2014
les politiques doivent en tout cas
rentrer dans cette dans cette dynamique
nous n'avons pas le choix que de
construire avec les politiques
donc c'est un travail de dialogue qu'il
faut continuer de construire sont ils à
la hauteur
je ne suis pas là pour délivrer des bons
points donc je ne le ferai pas
par en revanche je sais qu'une chose
c'est que c'est avec eux que les choses
peuvent avancer doivent avancer qu'il a
peut-être encore un travail de pédagogie
à travail de rencontres en travail
d'ouverture qu'il faut continuer sans
relâche
parce que c'est collectivement que les
choses peuvent bouger l'état livré que
tous les candidats par exemple à la
prochaine élection de législatives
devraient oui nous nous nous sommes en
train nous avons ouvert un cycle de
rencontres des principaux candidats
hier encore j'ai rencontré deux 2
candidats de partis différents et à
chacune de ses rencontres
j'évoque de manière très approfondie les
thèmes de ce livre puisque je crois que
c'est que nos politiques ont besoin
aussi d'être alimentée en termes d'idées
par des industriels par des chefs
d'entreprise est ce que nous faisons
nous mettons sur la table nos visions et
ça permet d'établir un échange qui
j'espère fera progresser les idées et et
en maintenant nos politiques vers des
solutions
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin manuel de redal rappelle que vous
êtes le président de l'association
patronale contact entreprises merci
bonne journée à vous merci
[Musique]
les lecteurs